un groupe détendu à la veille de jouer
sa survie à la Coupe du monde
des joueurs qui pratiquent à mettre le
ballon dans le filet ce qui a fait
défaut dans le match de mercredi qu'ils
ont dominé la sélection canadienne se
dit prête pour cette immense défi face à
la Croatie parce que Canada
[Applaudissements]
relevait de la science-fiction les
joueurs canadiens réalisent tout le
chemin parcouru
par contre la déclaration d'après match
mercredi du sélectionneur canadien
continue d'être une distraction
il avait dit à ses joueurs d'aller
botter le derrière des Croates pour
venger leur défaite cruelle une sortie
perçue par l'équipe et la presse croate
comme un manque de respect il tente
maintenant d'éviter la question pour ne
pas en rajouter
ma conjointe vous en veut lance-t-il à
la blague au journaliste croate je
parais moins bien que ça en personne la
sortie frondeuse de John hudman reflète
pendant l'état d'esprit de la jeune
sélection confiante en ses moyens
cette mini controverse révèle que le
Canada n'est plus pris à la légère par
les grandes nations du football
à un match très difficile dimanche c'est
une tâche colossale qui attend l'équipe
canadienne qui n'a jamais inscrit de
points ni même marqué de but dans son
histoire à la Coupe du Monde la Croatie
finalise du Mondial 2018 peut compter
sur le meilleur alignement de la planète
en milieu de terrain il suffit Leblanc
Radio-Canada Oum salam au Qatar